I'm dead
we're deep into the brunt of the summer
2023 season and I'm pretty sure a lot of
shows have caught your Collective eyes
whether they be hits that I was excited
for entering the season or some new
contenders that caught my eyes as the
season went by summer 2023 has given us
a healthy dose of new anime to enjoy
that's why I decided to put out my
current seasonal list now it's not the
end of the season there are some more
things I could change once it's all said
and done but here are 10 titles that
have caught my attention at a little
over the halfway point
thank you
[Music]
let's open up with one of the shows I
was excited about pre-season reign of
the seven spellblades
[Music]
fantasy magic and academies have been a
combination that I've enjoyed for quite
a while now however I assume a lot of
you has got quite a surprise with the
reign of the seven spellblades partly
because of how much the series reminded
everyone of Harry Potter seriously the
inspiration is there down to the overall
Vibes and the characters feeling like
Composites regardless it remains an
enjoyable watch that hits a lot of the
staple notes for a show like this I
enjoyed the fight Direction in general
as well as the darker themes that you
don't see as often with magic Academy
titles as someone who spoiled himself
with the novels I know that things get
way darker down the line and it creates
a nice balance with the vibrant
atmosphere the art at times suggests as
usual with these novel adaptations some
parts leave more elaboration and
development to be desired but overall
it's not a bad show at all
[Music]
next up we have Saint Cecilia and Pastor
Lawrence
[Music]
for the first in line of shows that I
didn't tackle in my pre-season preview
here's Saint Cecilia and Pastor Lawrence
oftentimes when we get anime featuring
the church or religious orders as themes
we often get the magical powers the
supernatural battles or the more lewd
sides of the coin it's not too often
that we get to see this religious setup
executed in a more normal Wholesome Way
there's a touch of the supernatural or
two as expected but it's certainly a
distant departure from what we've come
to expect from anime priests and the
like Saint Cecilia and Pastor Lawrence
is a slice of Life title that's
basically about showcasing the two main
characters daily lives and their
feelings for each other it is a really
sweet show that takes a slightly Slow
Burn approach showing the audience the
development of the main Duo's love story
in a gradual manner everything from the
Artistic Touch in the music creates this
heartwarming feeling that helps
exemplify the themes of the story Saint
Cecilia and Pastor Lawrence is a
heartwarming watch and why it doesn't
have the hijinks that something like a
school rom-com has it remains very sweet
and fulfilling
foreign
at number eight we take a look at helk
if I were to speak from an anecdotal
perspective I'd say Hulk is one of the
more interesting shows this season in
terms of reception people I know flocked
to it due to the virtue of it being a
fantasy show that's not an isakai
starring the usual reincarnated salary
man however the story and World building
for Hulk has been pretty good in its own
right even without those entices I
mentioned I like the direction it takes
with the whole demons versus Humans
conflict and it really juggles the Goofy
and serious aspects of the show
excellently the characters make for a
fun cast when put together and I can say
that the anime team really showed their
passion for the title with the way
things look and sound the latter really
comes through with giving the show the
feel it's going for short there may be
mishaps with the animation every now and
then but it hardly bugs the whole thing
down in my opinion especially with the
well-crafted story backing it up
seventh on the list is the girl I like
forgot her glasses
[Music]
oh this show this show is something
being a product of Studio go hands I
should have seen it a mile away that
they'd do something peculiar with the
visuals of the show with my key
experiences with the studio
characterized by shows like Kate and
capellion it shouldn't have surprised me
to see those hyper realistic backgrounds
that create a jarring contrast with the
characters just a noteworthy thing that
I'll preface before moving on to the
story which I can see the appeal of in
its unique way it's not too often that
we see romance between a guy and an
impaired girl and while there are a lot
of roads to take things up to 11 and
exaggerate the premise the show
surprisingly takes a slower Pace with
everything the comedy is there but it's
not exactly over the top in the way
people typically expect it's one of
those slower rom-coms that tries to pull
its appeal from the wholesome aspects
instead of the super sweet or comedic
moments overall this is one of those
middle of the line shows in the season
still enough to crack the top 10 for me
with how much the anime starve tries and
it's also got its momentsy
[Music]
the masterful cat is depressed again is
our next show
[Music]
so here's another surprise for you an
episodic show that gives us a warm story
of people's relationship with pets might
do the trick for you but I didn't
exactly expect a show like this to get
the level of quality it got from the
anime team boasting some great visuals
and animation it's a way to catch
everyone's attention at the start of the
show and you'll get hooked further with
the super enjoyable interactions between
our main characters it isn't a
completely new concept since it did
remind me of senko-san or Kobayashi in
terms of overall Vibes but watching this
show remains very enjoyable it's a slice
of life and doesn't have much of an
overarching story but it's one of the
shows that doesn't need that it's
something more down to earth more
wholesome and they're funny how I've
used that to describe half of the shows
I've talked about already but really
that's the energy being radiated by a
lot of the anime this season in spite of
the title the show looks good and makes
you feel good too it's a chill offering
if you give it a try foreign
continue let me ask you this have you
ever seen an anime advertisement that
really got your interest only to find
out that it doesn't stream in your
country trust me I understand this
feeling very well so make sure you're
making every cent you pay worth it with
expressvpn you see one of the neat
things about expressvpn is that it can
actually bypass Geo restrictions by
letting you change your online location
to wherever you want I've personally
been using it to watch the new Jiu Jitsu
Kaizen season on Netflix all you have to
do is open up expressvpn click on the
India server and boom you can now watch
some Gojo action on Netflix
expressvpn also encrypts your internet
connection and protects your online data
from potential threats if you think
that's all well too bad you're wrong
expressvpn has a vast network of servers
optimized for Speed by connecting to a
server near your location you can reduce
buffering and enjoy a smoother streaming
experience while watching anime so say
bye bye to the time wasted waiting for
your favorite anime shows to finish
loading if you're interested then why
not give it a try and find out how you
can get three months free by clicking
the link in the description box that's
expressvpn.com Vinnie tube now back to
the video Dark Gathering is up next
[Music]
foreign
and we finally exit The Chill Zone and
look at one of the more unnerving titles
this season has to offer dark Gathering
if you can remember from my pre-season
videos is one of the titles I was
looking forward to for this season as
far as I can tell with the episodes I've
seen so far dark Gatherings anime
manages to capture the spirit of the
manga giving us one hell of a horror
anime where the dark Gathering succeeds
to be scary is Up For Debate people have
different standards with this thing
however one thing that I can speak for
most people is that the show does nail
one thing right and that it gives us a
sense of unease it's an art I saw
prominently featured in something like
promised Neverland where the horror
isn't about the blood the violence and
all of that it's all about the
atmosphere and how the mood can swing
from relaxed to completely unsettling in
just a click of a finger with horror
being an unrepresented genre in the
modern anime sphere a really welcome
dark Gathering especially in its core
execution of the themes and the feel it
wants audiences to have
[Music]
Undead girl murderfoss is the fourth
ranked title for this season
foreign
mystery shows do have a charm don't they
with some popular hits like vanitas
Black Butler and the like it was
interesting to see how Undead girl
murder fast would hold up to me I think
it's got some good elements from his
predecessors that ultimately gave anime
fans a nice mystery slash detective show
to follow this season first off I do
think that the music and the way things
were drawn really hit the mark in terms
of capturing the intended Ambiance for
the show then combining Mysteries with
the supernatural proves to be a winning
formula and this one manages to
Captivate me through and through backed
by strong characters and puzzles that
people can indulge themselves in Undead
girl murderfoss is The Season's
underrated winner I don't see a lot of
people talking about the show much but
that's also likely due to the mystery
genre being not so popular still for
people who like to get themselves into
the genre of veterans who are craving
more this show is a welcome addition to
the season
foreign
Kenshin
the world of Legacy anime remakes can be
hit or miss I largely praised Hunter
Hunter for nailing it but more often
than not we get rather mediocre remakes
like the newest Shaman King it's not
like these shows are intolerably bad but
a lot of times in their rush to be more
faithful to the original in the limited
time that they have the shows lose some
of their soul if you get what I mean
thankfully this year's Rurouni Kenshin
managed to give us a great experience
while showing us a story that's closer
to the manga at the very least the
characters retain their characterization
and give off Nostalgia for long time
viewers those who've watched the
original Kenshin would get a strong
sense of familiarity at those characters
and events while getting a new
experience seeing them in action I'd say
for the newcomers to the series that
while the first Parts aren't bad we're
only kenshin's story hits his peak in
the shishio arc so that's something to
look forward to I do have to admit that
I felt initially a little bit lukewarm
towards the series I did welcome it it
did feel quite unnecessary in the grand
scheme of things having watched more of
it though I say that the execution of
this remake isn't that bad at all it
lets those of us from the 90s see the
good old characters and events from
childhood anime in a new light that's
quite a treat to watch
foreign
at number two please welcome my happy
marriage
[Music]
an intriguing addition to this season's
lineup is this novel adaptation one of
the strongest ones in fact how my happy
marriage is a show that doesn't mince
words with how it comes at you with some
dark and depressing themes but along
with them it shines on packets of light
that evoke hope and happiness if you've
noticed that I've just talked about
emotions it should help you prepare your
mindset in taking a dive into this show
this mix of themes is where the anime's
more traditional Source material becomes
more evident and it does give anime fans
a one-of-a-kind watch for this season
all of that framed with the historical
backdrop and the stunning art and you've
got something that a lot of people who
aren't even into anime can greatly
appreciate everything comes together to
give a very immersive experience About
Love and Hope in the midst of darkness
my happy marriage is by far the most
artistic amongst the summer 2023 anime
if we're going to be looking at the more
traditional sense of art it looks very
beautiful and it will surely take you
through a whirlwind of emotions
foreign
[Music]
hi
finally we end with what I feel is the
best non-sequel of the season song 100.
[Music]
Zone 100 came in with an impact an
impact that I frankly didn't expect to
see from a zombie apocalypse show sure
the story is interesting and so are the
characters but what really drove the
anime Community is the animation
cinematic would be a good way to
describe how the entire thing looks and
if there's anything we've learned from
the big hits of the past years
production quality could be the
Difference Maker that would allow a good
anime to break through the glass ceiling
and become the Talk of the Town just ask
Demon Slayer and Jiu Jitsu Kaizen fans
in addition to that I'd also give some
mentions to what makes zom100 a hit the
setup with the characters feels like
something a lot of the audience can
resonate with the feeling of just
toiling away in a directionless path
before a once in a lifetime apocalypse
reinvigorates you and gives meaning to
your life does seem like a theme that's
a differing extent we can all relate to
or even wish for all that bundled with a
thrilling ride is more about the
survival and excitement instead of the
horror of a zombie apocalypse and you've
got the recipe for one of the most
promising big hits of Summer 2023 it's
easy to brush aside as yet another
zombie flick with a new make attached
but experiencing it yourself does give
you a show that almost immediately sucks
you in and straps you down for a very
fun ride
and those are my picks for the best
non-sequels for summer 2023. let me see
what you've had to say in the comments
section down below and don't forget to
shout out your favorite titles from
Summer 2023 I hope you had a great time
watching this video and I hope you can
also check out the other videos on my
channel and discover something that you
might like thanks for watching and I
wish you a good day ahead of you see you
next time